Teen Titans go is one of Cartoon
Network's most popular shows and Pokemon
is one of the most popular franchises
out there today we've combined the two
and made some brand-new Pokemon
characters Raven has to be our favorite
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and hit that subscribe button
today we're checking out 10 teen titans
go characters as Pokemon Tim Drake let's
start with one of the main Teen Titans
go characters Tim Drake is a member of
Team Robin there's some controversy
revolving around his character in Teen
Titans go as the show references him as
Dick Grayson but if you're a hardcore
Teen Titans fan you know that they are
completely separate people
appearance-wise Tim Drake stands out
with his black hair and a red and green
outfit he has super strength and is very
skilled in hand-to-hand combat and then
on the other side we have Evie a
powerful evolution Pokemon because of
its DNA Evie can evolve into many
different creatures depending on its
location which means it is super
adaptable to any given situation pretty
awesome right so what would happen if
you'd combined Tim Drake with Evie
here's TV an awesome looking new species
Pokemon doesn't it look amazing
imagine what would happen if Tim Drake's
amazing fighting skills would pair up
with Edie's ability to evolve into
practically anything and grow even more
powerful we bet this Pokemon would own
any arena out there Tim Drake is voiced
by Scott menville
who voiced several other cartoon
characters we can't put our finger on
who would voice TV but we believe its
voice would be slightly sweeter than
Scott Mendel's
I choose UTV Starfire along with Tim
Drake Starfire is also one of the main
protagonists on Teen Titans go she's
absolutely gorgeous and we adore her
long pink hair did you know that her
real name is coriander she usually wears
a purple and gray outfit and she's known
for superhuman powers and her passionate
personality as her choice of Pokemon we
chose Pikachu Pikachu much like Starfire
is very charismatic this electric tight
Mouse Pokemon is the most popular and
recognizable Pokemon out there and you
can't help but love him both Starfire
and Pikachu have similar superpowers as
an electric pokemon Pikachu is known for
its electricity storing abilities while
Starfire can shoot ultraviolet energy
from her hands the two would definitely
get along but what would happen if we'd
combine them into a single Pokemon
character are you ready the result would
be a pink Pikachu and we think it's name
would be starch
- starfire is voiced by hynden Walch
who's also known for her role as
Princess Bubblegum in Adventure Time
would start to have a different voice or
would it not speak at all we're totally
in love with this mix of the two
characters and we bet their energy
levels would go through the roof this
proves that everything looks better in
pink including our beloved Pikachu and
isn't starch you just the cutest name
ever if you want to watch just one more
video the premium is a platform where
you should go get early access to videos
from the things the taco the trendy the
richest and many other great channels in
one place with ad free browsing click
this link to sign up for free to the
premium and get ready to binge watch
videos from your favorite channels Beast
Boy will wait until the end to show you
our favorite character of the show but
Beast Boy comes close second how can you
not love Beast Boy as the name suggests
he's a beast but he's also a boy his
real name is Garfield Logan and he can
transform into any animal at any time
Beast Boy is a hopeless romantic and
he's also incredibly cute we're pairing
him up with Charmander along with
Pikachu Charmander is also one of the
most recognizable characters ever this
fire type lizard Pokemon won the hearts
of many so what would have happened if
we paired up Charmander and Beast Boy we
think the two have many qualities that
would complement each other while Beast
Boy has the power of shape-shifting
charmander's fire abilities make it
exceptionally strong the two could make
a powerful character and we'll call it
char boy check it out char boy basically
looks like Charmander with green skin
it's fire is now purple and black which
is much cooler and we bet it's stronger
too
Beast Boy is voiced by greg cipes who
gave a voice to several characters
across the ben 10 series okay we
seriously can't decide which name is
cuter is it starchy or char boy if you
guys ever need help naming your Pokemon
you know where you need to go black fire
black fire is star fires older sister
who's not so nice but that's okay
because we still love her this purple
haired girls mission is to be as mean as
possible to her little sister black fire
takes it to the point where she makes
her sister dress up as her in a normal
sister world this would all be okay but
black buyer's intention is to get her
sister arrested to serve time instead of
her but as superhero black fire is
pretty wonderful along with her flying
abilities she also
has the same ultraviolet energy
projection as Starfire we decided to
pair her up with Lucario one of the most
powerful aura pokémon this impressive
creature can read thoughts and feelings
as well as control the aura of others
imagine Blackfyre gaining access to all
this power we're naming this pairing
black are--oh this illustration belongs
to a tumblr user G Goku Hana just at a
tail and you'll get a perfect
combination of the powerful Lucario and
black fire black Oreo is on the rise and
we'd love to see what this pokemon could
do in an actual arena black fire is
voiced by adventure times hynden walch
since Lucario can mimic human speech we
think black Oreos voice would be much
darker and mysterious seriously we're on
a roll with creating new catchy Pokemon
names and making these popular
characters more powerful than ever
Batgirl while Batgirl only makes cameos
throughout Teen Titans go
we still had to add her on this list
Batgirl has long ginger hair and she
sports a similar mask and black and
yellow outfit as Batman her role in Teen
Titans go isn't really important but we
know that batgirls powers include
SuperSpeed incredible strength
hand-to-hand combat and many other
skills she gained during her training
well we wish Batgirl would have a
significant role in Teen Titans go
we love that she's still kind of
mysterious in the series we've paired
her up with a mysterious pokémon called
Sneasel Sneasel has sharp claws and it's
smart and sneaky
just like Batgirl as a pokemon it's
pretty vicious it feeds itself on eggs
and nests while the parents are away it
seems pretty cute doesn't it so what
would happen if we pair up Batgirl in
Sneasel meat sneeze girl well this
creature might not have an appealing
name it really looks awesome
this design belongs to glitched puppet
on deviantART just imagine Sneasel
having a bat mask and you'd be looking
at sneeze girl did you know that bat
girl is voiced by the same person that
voices Raven we can imagine sneeze girl
having a sweet voice that would mask her
viciousness we want to see a battle
between sneeze girl and Black REO
although sneeze girl and our next
combination might be interesting to
Batman you know we can't talk about Teen
Titans go without mentioning Batman just
like Batgirl Batman started off making
small cameos and Teen Titans go but he
eventually became a recurring character
but Batman is such an important
character that we can't possibly leave
him out of this list
Batman is one of the most recognizable
characters in general and we believe
everyone can tell who he is we've paired
him up with the most recognizable
Pokemon of all time
she was a popular choice of Pokemon in
this video but we promise you'll want to
see this combination here statue isn't
this the most adorable illustration
you've ever seen Batman's strength
combined with Pikachu's electricity
abilities could make some serious damage
we'd love to see bat you in action
although we can't imagine it having the
sweet voice of regular Pikachu Batman's
been voiced by many actors throughout
the years but we can imagine that you
would have a male and slightly sped up
voice that would sound almost like a
chipmunk we can imagine it will be
totally sweet and then attack when its
opponent least expects it out of all
characters we've shown you so far which
one was your favorite was it TV star Chu
char boy Batou or black Oreo well we're
not done with picking the cutest names
for these Pokemon characters Tara did
you know that the word Tara actually
means earth Tara's ability makes that
much more sense Tara is voiced by Ashley
Johnson who also voiced the character in
the original Teen Titans series although
Tara is Teen Titan gos villain we still
love her Tara pretended to have feelings
for Beast Boy to get into Teen Titans
secret files her plans didn't quite work
out because she was discovered by Raven
take that Tara Tara has long blonde hair
yellow shorts brown boots gloves and a
black top she's able to bend the earth
and manipulate it to her liking which is
pretty cool we've paired Tara with
Emolga a sky squirrel Pokemon meet Tim
Olga along with having flying abilities
Emolga is actually an electric-type
pokémon imagine how powerful Tomoko
could be if it were able to fly produce
electricity and have full control of the
earth
it sounds pretty awesome doesn't it this
illustration of Tara and Emolga together
was created by a deviantART user linked
Snivy lover and we totally loved it
Emolga actually doesn't need much change
as it already perfectly blends with Tara
style these two are meant to be come on
let's make Tomoka happen it would look
so unbelievably cute Beast Boy we love
beast voice so much we have to feature
him again this little green looking
darling totally stole our hearts Beast
Boy is super passionate and has many
love interests on the show including
Tara he's also probably the only
character that's allowed to flirt with
the last character on our list but we
can't imagine anyone else being able to
have that much success Beast Boy is
pretty awesome but what's even more
awesome is his Pokemon version it's
Beast Boy and Pikachu also known as
beast - this illustration belongs to the
talented Raven evert from deviantART
check out the incredible detail in this
Beast Boy and Pikachu actually have a
lot in common they're both ridiculously
cute and allow themselves to have some
fun
since Beast Boy has the natural ability
to shape-shift beasts - Pokemon would
only make sense don't you just love its
cute green face combined Pikachu's
electrical ities with beast boy's
metamorphosis and you'll get one of the
strongest Pokemon out there beast - it's
the next big thing and although it looks
incredibly cute it's totally ready for
battle we told you we're really good at
creating brand new Pokemon names
speaking of Pikachu did you know that
the popular character actually has a
protein named after it the protein has
lightning-fast moves and shocking
electric effects sounds like Pikachu
doesn't it add a green face a
shape-shifting ability and you'll get
beast chew cyborg
if Beast Boy is our second favorite
character cyborg is our close third
there's just something about this
friendly guy that you can't ignore
even though cyborgs the strongest thing
around he's incredibly friendly and
lovable he prefers pizza and video games
to fighting crime which pretty much
makes him instantly likable and
relatable most of us would probably
choose pizza
cyborg also known as Victor stone has
superhuman strength he can also turn his
arms into cannons and shoot lasers out
of parts of his body pretty cool right
we featured this Pokemon before and no
it's not pikachu lucario is so powerful
it deserves to be paired up with the
strongest Teen Titans go character meet
Lucca Borg the ultimate powerhouse
imagine you could combine Lucario's
psychic abilities with cyborg strength
this illustration belongs to deviantART
user cyborg Lucario and it's absolutely
perfect wouldn't this be the strongest
Pokemon ever it looks like it's
completely unstoppable and we'd love to
see it in action cyborg is voiced by
Khary Payton who also voiced cyborg and
several other DC Universe series we bet
he'd also voiced Luca Borg unfortunately
we don't think Luca board would be as
friendly and laid back at cyborg is but
who knows maybe he'd be so powerful the
whole thing would just become too boring
Raven and now let's move on to the
princess of darkness and one of our
favorite teen titans go characters Raven
is known to be Moody and sarcastic her
personality might be easily off-putting
for some but as you know she's also the
most level-headed member of the Teen
Titans group her dark cloak is what
influences her personality and she's
often seen as quite mysterious
we thought we'd pair her with MU a
psychic-type pokémon that's incredibly
rare knew pretty much resembles a cat
and he's one of the most powerful
characters ever
the level-headedness of Raven and Muse
ability to use practically any power
that exists would make a perfect Pokemon
character we're calling it Navin check
it out
Mew is now purple and has Ravens dark
look while ravenous protagonists and
Teen Titans go we have no doubt she'd be
tempted to test out absolutely all of
her powers as maven but whatever she
does we hope she never loses her sarcasm
Raven is originally voiced by Tara
Strong who also voiced bubbles in the
Powerpuff Girls with such strong
abilities we're pretty sure maven could
learn how to mimic human speech even as
a pokemon who wouldn't love a sassy
Pokemon we might have just created the
most powerful character ever maven is
definitely our favorite pair from this
list but then again we've shown you some
pretty powerful new Pokemon characters
and that's it for ten teen titans go
characters as pokemon for more videos
like this one check out 10 Teen Titans
go characters in real life see you next
time
[Music]